Speaker 1: We're taking calls via discord, just as
a reminder to everybody waiting to chat with me if
you actually want the opportunity to talk. Your
nickname in the waiting lobby on Discord needs
to be your name and where you're calling from
or where you're calling from and your name. A
lot of people with nicknames are not going to
get called on. Okay. Just as just as a heads
up. So everybody understands that. Let's go
next to Tristan from Boston. Tristan, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, what's up?
Speaker 1: How are you?
Speaker 3: Feeling okay? Good. So, um. My
question would be you remember a while back the
detective work by that American muckrakers
pack is what ended up getting Madison Cawthorn.
Fired. Well, you think?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I don't know that
Cawthorn lost only because of the salacious stuff
released about him. I don't know. But I remember
that. I remember the American muckrakers pack
in the stuff that they released. Certainly, yes.
Speaker 3: Do you think we'll hear from them
again in actually succeeding, in smearing
someone enough to get them out of Congress?
Speaker 1: So I don't remember if it was the same
people who tried with Lauren Boebert and it didn't
go anywhere because it wasn't very well-sourced or
if that was a different organization. I just
don't remember offhand. But it's sort of a
question about a prediction. I have no idea. I
don't know if they have dirt on someone else,
but it's certainly conceivable that we would.
Speaker 3:
The site fire Boebert is still up and I assume
it will be up for as long as it takes for her to.
Leave Congress.
Speaker 1: All right. Well,
we will keep an eye on it.
Speaker 3: And other than that,
the their site right now is just a bunch
of criminal Republicans not looking. So.
Caught in a not so hot poses. Fair? Well, I guess
it's what the best we can hope for. For now.
Speaker 1: All right, Tristan.
Very good. We'll keep an eye on it.
Speaker 3: Cool. Thanks.
Speaker 1: All right. Tristan from
Boston with a very important declaration. Let's
go next to Philip from Germany. Philip, welcome.
Speaker 4: Hello. Hello? Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Well, so I can hear you. There is a
static hiss in the background whenever you talk.
Speaker 4: Okay. I don't really know why,
but my main question is that basically,
back in the times of the Civil War,
the winners of the Democratic and
Republican Party were kind of reversed,
where the Democrats were two one with 50 slaves
and every ham Lincoln was from the Republicans
who have flipped, freeing the slaves and so on.
And nowadays, well, it's all kinda in reverse,
especially when you have Confederate flags
being raised to January six and all that,
and you have an idea how that reversal came to be.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there's actually been multiple
reversals. And I think, you know, this can be very
confusing even to Americans. So my advice on this
issue is to think about it in the following way.
The right wing was in favor of owning slaves and
the party name that was the correct name at the
time is less relevant than the fact that it was
the political right that wanted the slaves and
the political, quite frankly, center and left and
even to some degree center right that did not.
And that makes it so you don't have to remember
when the party realignments took place.
Speaker 4: Okay. But still kind of weird
that the Republicans were center or
perhaps even center left. Not sure.
Speaker 1: Well, remember, not all
Republicans were Republicans. Not all
of Lincoln's Republicans wanted to end
slavery. That's that's Lincoln did, but
not the entire Republican Party did not want to.
Speaker 4: Also interesting, I guess, but yeah, it
kind of happens to go that way that basically the
Democrats were were hard line into slaves and the
and Lincoln's direction was. Yeah. Against this.
Speaker 1: Yes. I would even want to double check
that because I don't even know for sure that that
that is that Democrats were into slaves. Let me
double check, because there were multiple parties
at the time. But I'm going to let you go because
that hissing is just so bad. Okay. Oh, sorry.
Okay. No problem. Okay. We'll get that figured
out for next time. But that is that is quite
an audio element that was taking place there